okay so thank you I'm speak on the block
length scaling of polar codes continuing
some and this is a joint work with
dinner golden okay so let's consider
some discrete memoryless channel w we
symmetric opacity I w for simplicity
simplicity suppose the w is symmetric
and so on I w is equal to the capacity
and the goal is to communicate the
traitor without probability Apple
bounded by some please specify to a
short p 0 and if you are given a
capacity cheering family of goods then
for any hour less than C we can find the
code with the from the family with
recently large block length n such that
we there already will be below the
pre-specified treasure fundamental
question is how does n scale with
respect to the gap between call rate and
channel capacity is all complexity
considerations we know that the scaling
is polynomial is expect to the inverse
gap between C and out this is the best
possible and it is also achievable what
about finite length scaling way of
computationally efficient capacity
achieving codes this is a different
story much more complicated and
much more complicated question and
actually the first results only appeared
very recently they appeared after the
introduction of polar codes introduced
by Oregon in 2009 computational
complexity is o n log n so they they are
efficient and it was shown the block
length scale is polynomially but the
question is what is now that we noted
its polynomial it remains to ask what is
the how small can be setting you so
there were a series of works in this on
this topic in this short time interval
from 2013 and until today and the best
result today is that mu is between 3.55
in 4.7 and the similar scaling in n
holds also in other problems like slow
see source coding and various problems
in there going to use an information
till
so okay so if this is the situation
regarding new the question is how can we
improve or maybe generalize what else
can be done so one thing that is natural
to think about is to apply a general
polarization cleaners Oh to apply
non-binary for all codes so recent
resulted we held this workshop is that
also for qaali paulo codes from coupon
and scales polynomial Eve is expected to
ask a polynomial but in the poof mu is
very large so can you do better so in a
recent work that we submitted we show
that for Q equal to you show numerically
the 4q equally much loyal values of MU
can be obtained and we think that the
technique can be applied to idle values
of mine Q but we're not done yet ok so
let's fix notation notations about polo
codes block lengths is n equal to 2 the
smaller generator matrix is GN here is
the information vector X is the code
will equals you GN so also that we have
a binary DMC w so from X to Y and X is a
01 the channel output vector is why and
so this induces a this induces a
probability distribution is forbidden to
a distribution and from this we can
define sub-channels in the standard way
and what we can show this that typically
either the information of this
typical subchannel is very good so the
subchannel is almost perfect oh it is a
useless the information is very small
okay we encode and decode you in code
the code in the standard where no point
to elaborate on that this point the
coding is using the successive
consolation decoder and we know that
there for Alec on and the Delta showed
it for I less than C their probability
goes 0 very fast now in order to analyze
the polarization we use this trip
process of channels which is defined as
follows suppose that be want bir iid
random variables and they are uniformly
distributed they are binary we start
from a phone w 0 which is at the root w0
is is w and then we will progressively
define w n on 1 2 to the n so forth and
now at each step WN minus is formed by
technol the convolution between W&W
while w + is found by variable node
convolution between wnw and this
terminology uses standard factor graph
notation for example you can see it in
the book of Richardson and Lou banker we
know that the information of the w- is
the bed channel and develop loses the
good channel and the average information
w- and w bruce is the same as W so we
have this random process
and the relation between this and room
it was shown by Oregon that the relation
between these random process and the sub
channels that we have in their practice
is that for example if we look at
bhattacharya parameter of which
subchannel the probability that Z n I
will Adam variable here is zwn
probability that it will be in a a B is
deflection of subchannels little inside
a B and similarly for other for the
information for the symmetric
information and so on and this this we
can show that for any fixed small delta
positive Delta we have that we have
polarization which is summarized here
how do we prove a finite length skin so
so that the this one of the
possibilities is to use the bhattacharya
parameter and so if we start with a
channel w producing w + + w minus s two
sons then we know that Z W plus is equal
to this square w while cw- satisfies
these two inequalities so if we define
some function f 0 which is 0 it the
boundaries 0 1 and positive in the
interval 0 1 we define this function in
this way and then it can be shown that
the expected value of f 0 z n is
exponentially decreasing in little n
this can be used to show using markov
inequality that the probability that z n
has not been polarized this is also the
flexion of channels that have not been a
polarized is exponentially small now
from here the poof goes quite can go
quite fast after we've shown this we can
say something say a similar statement
about the fraction of channels the
testing polarized and for me we can we
have this relation which is that what is
the probability that the channel is
information carrying so it is I double-
some small exponentially small town
and then following standard now standard
argument of Aragon we get the collect
scanning result which is summarized here
so this is how we can proceed with
binary codes now let's move on to the
second part which is what we do for our
QR codes so instead of Z it will be more
convenient to use the information
asymmetric information and given a QR
the input channel w again w minus is the
check node convolution between two
copies of W and W plus is the variable
node convolution between two copies of W
and we would like to obtain this kind of
mount for some function epsilon L I
double as motivated by the binary case
we also define FK x recursively in this
manner and the rest of the analyzes is
very similar to the binary case if I
would like to label it the first step I
can little bit elaborate on the first
step so like similarly to the binary
case if we define lk x like this and lk
is the supremum of lk x in the interval
0 1 then let's look at the EF ki n plus
1 we know that I n plus 1 is iron plus
with probability half and I n minus with
poverty up so the expected value is this
now we also know that I n plus and I n
minus n plus increases design plus
epsilon and I n minus might must be I n
minus epsilon because the Sun there is a
conservation of some
informations so if we take here the
supremum we have an inequality and now
using our definition of FK plus one
which was because obviously we get this
inequality from here we can by applying
this basic relation we can repeat it
several times and get this inequality
and now dividing by f0 and multiplying
back by f0 and using the definition of
lk which immediately get this repeating
this relation several times we get that
EF 0 I n is exponentially decreasing and
by knockoffs inequality it can be seen
that we can say a statement on the
fraction of non polarizing channels and
the rest is the same as the binary case
so they all analyzes that we propose is
very similar to the binary case except
for one difficult problem which is how
to obtain a tight bound how to obtain a
tight bound on epsilon L IW or how to
obtain a good inequality good rebound
on IW between IW and between I EE and I
w- out how can we obtain a good royal
bound so for the binary case there are
lit this kind of problems are called the
extremes of information combining
sometimes we have a result but there is
no results for Q greater than 2 and
apparently it is very difficult to find
some simple nice formula so we went to
be suggested a numerical method instead
which I now focusing the rest of my talk
okay so we follow notation in a calzone
and telat I'll which also worked on the
q alley channel for lossy source coding
and given a qrt channel w y given x we
define wy in this way let's define v why
is this vector well eating which is
actually W Y given X normalized and by
this definition the vector V Y is on the
simplex so it's the sum is one and each
element is a positive little and non- it
is very simple to show that I w can be
expressed like this or like this where
whe is defined here so this is very
now consider two channels wa in WB the
check node convolution between W&W be
denoted here is this ball is by a by
definition this is the definition from
this definition it is immediately to see
that this and also to add the relation
between expressing to evaluation
expressing VA check not convolution be
it is simply the cost the cost
correlation circular cross correlation
between vb and VA now define this
function
under this definition we have the
following the symmetric capacity of whi
convolution b is equal to this why is
that so because because of this so we
can see right here and using our
definition of G we get this inequality
our definition of g8 the fact that W is
w a times W B which was cell phone we
get this inequality now using the
definition of wa head and WB head we get
you can like this like this okay now
suppose the G supposed it we are lucky
and G g1 g2 is concave separately not
jointly I just needed to be concave
separately in g1 and g2 then we can say
that we have this i whi convolution bin
and becomes less equal than g applied to
i wa and I iwb if G is not there we are
not lucky and it is not ok maybe you can
find an upper bound and upper lip but
you can find the function which is
larger than G which will be concrete
which which is concave in our case we
take two identical copies so a is equal
B and W minus is the check node
convolution of wnw and we have this also
I w- I w- is critical to this this is
our epsilon RI w now one of our main and
numerical observations was that at least
for Q equal three a QSC channel provides
an excellent approximation to the
solution but it is not completely the
it's only an approximation we need to
massage it a little bit in order to
obtain a account what is a QC eight in a
QC like BSC for the QR cast is defined
by if they'll probability is P it this
is the disease
okay so first we will it's it's not very
difficult to prove some food some we can
prove some properties of G some of them
are very easy to prove like if WA and ee
p el bosque QC then the wa check not
conclusion be is also QC and then gravy
quality we can express the symmetric
information within quality and we have
another lemma which is also this Leonard
and the w when WA and WBL q SE channels
the in an extreme point in the
Lagrangian in the the definition of G g1
g2 this is also you can also prove some
other results we can show that we don't
need the qualities here you can take
these inequalities this is also very
simple to show and we have this lemma
that says that if we actually write this
G g1 g2 as the 1 minus the minimum value
as fu where fu takes the other variable
v then this fu itself is concave and
actually what this means is that the g g
one g clue can be computed efficiently
using algorithms for concave
minimization over a convex region
because if we look at a few it is
defined over a convex do is defined in a
convex region and Jeff you is a concave
so it's a minimization of a concave in a
convex region there are efficient
algorithms for doing it they well they
provide both apple and loyal bounds
iteratively of course if we had the
other problem like
of maximizing context pub maximizing
concave a functioning convex the magnets
would be better but this is not the case
in but nevertheless there are efficient
algorithms in this case to end our the
number of variables in our problem is
not large stick at least when q is not
too low a know there are some other
lemurs which have some other properties
on Gigi's a monotonically increasing and
it's symmetric some of them are also
very simple these llamas are more
complicated more difficult to show we
can write the explicit the expression
for G g1 g2 for small g1 g2 and for g1
g2 sufficiently close to 1 and Q equal 3
we if this actually generalizes also for
the general case of it at least a dis
lemma so very large oh thank you here we
need to do some egg and value analysis
here it's some other way observation and
so for the extremes we know in explicit
value for disk functions and it matches
the value of the GU se which I was
talking all let's look at some numerical
result so if we look at the contour of
the function G g1 g2 as I said it's a
functions two variables we can compute
it and by the method that
educated using dilemma that I one of
dilemmas that I indicated about that fu
is concave we can see the TG is indeed
likely increasing from 0 0 to 1 1 it's
of course symmetric we look at the first
derivative for any fixed g2 the
derivatives with respect to G 1 is
pleasing and it's 0 0 g 1 a when g one
approach is one and if you look the most
interesting thing is if what happens if
we look at the second derivative so we
fixed we don't need we only need the
function G g1 g2 to be concave with
respect to one of the with respect to G
1 when g2 is fixed all the other way
around because this is the symmetric
function so it's enough to concentrate
on the case well gee when g2 is a fixed
and we look at the second derivative of
this function and so we get disc on
tools and if we look at this function
it's not well we are not completely
lucky because G is not entirely concave
but it is quite close to being concave
and we can make it concave how can make
it how can we make it contain so
actually
here this
our function is goes like this and then
it's concrete so I as a tank and the
faucet is exaggerated it because it's
most of the region in pain most of the
region
most of the region as can be yes we can
see here for most values of g1 it will
be concave only for very small values of
the g1 it will not be contained but we
can pass a tangent and so we can make it
we can obtain a convex a concave Apple
bound so this can be done and actually
we need to do it in both dimensions so
we suggest doing it right here and in
this way we can obtain a concave upper
bound on G now you might be concerned
about the fact that this G we don't have
an explicit function ecology but this
can also be so actually we noticed it
you can obtain a closed-form concave
upper bound on this G given by this
function this is concave function this
can be checked you think all solid
matica something like that and it is an
upper bound on the function that we are
there on the only 20 g and so it can be
used in their bound but if you use this
solution we get a slight degradation
compared to using edgy stuff so it felt
to him i will show results box with this
and business
so really this god shows that the GQ SC
style is indeed con que with respect to
G one and the same Vegeta this is the
perhaps the most interesting thing in
the bottom line because if you look at
the Apple bound it a loyal bound between
IW and I w- you see that this is the
blue line is the BSC is the Q equal to
case well we know from extreme of
information combining that BSC is the is
the yields the bound for Q equal three
our numerical code so that this is the
bound and it is above the Q equal to K
so this is nice although but the gate is
quite small if you look at the suppose
it you just look the take the q SE and
look what is the difference between you
assume that the solution is given by the
QSR engine then you see that there is
not much difference between the red line
and disk you see it is a little bit over
optimistic regarding the bound but it is
very close to there will explode the
rebound the day okay and so if you use
this bound with distal the concave
gee then the scaling of n is a dish
which is much better than was known
before and actually it is it can
probably be improved when using the
newer techniques presented by a month
early Hasani and ivanka so it might be
it might well be the case that this 6.5
can at least decrease by one and Perez
buy mobic because the in the binary case
we are using Bhattacharya it were using
symmetric information perhaps we didn't
try to too much too we actually I will
work it the first stage concentrated on
obtaining better bounds on I w- I w- we
didn't try to improve that too much
the conclusion you saw that the block
length of polar code scale it is known
that the block lengths of Polanco sched
polynomially with respect to the English
gap between code rate and capacity for
binary and now also ternary codes this
polynomial is low degree only the
technique a can be extended to larger
Q's one main issue is to consider is the
question whether the scaling actually
discuss the creases with respect to Q
this is an opener this is an open
problem which being considered in the
future okay
think we have a requirement that came
but eventually the talk has to ask you a
question or make a comment enough stocks
yeah I have a good question so the poor
code you're suing art is the 1 1 1
matrix I guess is one other choice you
can do at 1 1 2 or one this is the
standard polarization is the standard
polarization colonel but with QR in not
binary of course it is it only polarizes
for point Q there are examples well you
can show the polarization right not okay
when q is not time one interesting
possibility perhaps this type of bounds
can be used also with generalized a fake
illness this is one
is there any reason to believe this will
be monotonic well understood i I really
don't know this is a what is the
dependence in which is very cool I mean
if it is really I don't know even if it
I don't know if it will be i'm not
talking about forget about the scaling
let's just look at the dismount I w- I w
minus the question is whether it impose
miscue I don't know if its toll
this is not known and again this is
really you see that we could not come up
with something nice like in the binary
case we had to do some numerical work to
bypass this partner
thank you very much